Bangladesh's Prime Minister Sheikh
Hasina has secured a third term in
office after a landslide victory in the
country's general election the Electoral
Commission says Sheikh Hasina his
coalition won 288 of 300 seats in
parliament in Sunday's foot but the
election was tarnished by violence as
well as accusations of Bert rigging and
voter suppression opposition leader
Kemal Hussain has called for new
elections both the ruling party and the
opposition reported attacks on their
supporters and candidates over a dozen
people were killed during violence on
the election day all right i'll
correspondent Nimisha jaiswal is
standing by in the capital for us in
dhaka hi Nimisha so Prime Minister
Sheikh Hasina's Alliance managed to
secure all but 12 of 300 seats does this
result this very strong result come as a
surprise well this result does
definitely does not come as a surprise
and not just because the few by polls
that were conducted did predict a
landslide victory for Sheikh Hasina this
is also because of what the opposition
has been pointing out for the last three
weeks the opposition was only cobbled
together a few short months before the
election but in the weeks of campaigning
leading up to it
opposition supporters were arrested and
attacked that's happened in both camps
but the opposition of course alleged
that even its candidates were facing
harassment by the authorities and this
is not just claims by the opposition
even foreign observers and human rights
groups said that this was not a level
playing field the surprise would have
actually been if the opposition had
scored more than 12 seats
all right Nimisha having said all of
this and how credible then is this
election
well the credibility of this election
has definitely been drawn into question
DW itself over here has spoken to at
least two waters who faced some kind of
intimidation or harassment at the polls
they said that they were not able to
cast their vote freely one of them even
said that his vote was already cast for
him he was not able to actually put down
the stamp on the other and we also have
reports of reporters saying that they
witnessed ballot box stuffing but any
decisions and any investigation into
these discrepancies would have to be
done by the Election Commission the
Election Commission has the authority
who which can actually declare any kind
of water rigging so far the Election
Commissioner said that the word has gone
through freely and fairly but of course
there are allegations against the
Election Commission as well offer bias
towards the ruling party okay Tammy sure
we know that the opposition leader he's
demanded a new vote that would become
al-hussein what is the likelihood that
the opposition will be able to challenge
the results well a short history lesson
actually comes into play here the
opposition is demanding that the
would-be rican ducted under caretaker
government that a ruling government
should not oversee award this has
happened once before when the current
ruling party was on the opposition and
back in 96 they successfully managed to
push through for a reelection under a
caretaker government they rejected an
election where the opposition leader
Khaleda Zia actually came to par but
observers over here and political
political commenters say that this is
very unlikely right now because the
current opposition the Bangladesh
Nationalist Party just does not wield
enough power to actually push through
such a demand this demand was pushed
through in 96 by massive nationwide
protests by the party in opposition then
currently the BNP just does not have the
power to push re-election through all
right that's Nimisha Jaya our
correspondent reporting from the
Bangladeshi capsule Dhaka for us thank
you